mi dica cosa sa
bambino oltre che
piangere giocare il disordine sporcare
qualche altro idea
nessuna
ve lo dico io
un bambino può insegnare in particolare
un bambino questi ne ha venduto tre cose
essere felice senza alcun motivo in ogni
occasione
essere sempre impegnati in qualcosa e
cercare di ottenere qualunque cosa che è
soggetto del proprio desiderio
quindi se un bambino può insegnare
qualcosa perché non può fare un ragazzo
nessuno inutile in questo mondo sia la
capacità di far pesare meno qualcosa un
altro uomo
ad esempio un ragazzo a smorzare i
momenti di panico
oppure dire qualcosa di divertente
durante momenti difficili essere
creativo se essere testardo oppure se a
farsi trascinare
questo basta per volere qualcosa
ma partiamo dall'inizio
dalla comune concezione per cui i
giovani sono apatici e menefreghisti
anni anni trascorsi a sentire il peso
del tempo che passa e del futuro che
arriva
responsabilità che si accumulano e
persone che continuano imperterrite ad
associarci a nulla facenti schiavi dei
social network è stato attenti per ciò
che può accadere
la nostra è un età considerata
impermeabile ai sentimenti che i grandi
prova ne hanno provato quindi e molto
spesso sentiamo dirci non sai veramente
così è la vita
il dolore non sai cosa sia
oppure la scuola è una passeggiata
voglio vedere cosa riuscirai a
concludere quando dovrai cercare un
lavoro oppure ancora ma non fai mai
niente
com'è possibile che tu sia stanco
ora vogliamo raccontarvi due storie
quella di pietro e di nunzia
pietro una persona che ha sempre vissuto
della propria passione che ha viaggiato
per tutti quando insieme a sua moglie e
che ha vissuto in germania per più di
trent'anni
fino a quando però sua moglie viene a
mancare e di conseguenza insieme a lei
anche nella sua autosufficienza
questo perché a pietro un giorno viene
diagnosticato il parkinson
quindi si ritrova spaesato rimasto solo
senza la sua compagna di vita
e senza la sua macchina da cucire
perché che ci ho messo sarto colui che
dirige e mette in pratica le proprie
idee
colui che concretizza le proprie idee
partendo un semplice bozzetto
pietro ritorna nella sua città natale
in italia
però molte cose sono cambiate e anche
lui
ho avuto la fortuna di conoscere pietro
durante un'attività di volontariato
e la sosteniamo insegnato tanto
sono riuscita a
supportarlo nei suoi momenti di
fragilità e nella sua quotidianità
stravolta un giorno all'altro da questi
ragazzi che lui chiama boy scout
nunzia invece è una ragazza piena di
vita con la passione per la scrittura
solare che un giorno ha segnato la
nostra vita
succede che nunzia si ritrova
catapultata in una realtà un po troppo
grande per lei una realtà fatta di
continui spostamenti
continui terapie continui sacrifici
nunzia è stata per noi quel bambino
citato all'inizio che ci ha insegnato
qualcosa
tramite il suo percorso
un percorso durante il quale il nostro
tentativo di sostenerla si è tradotta in
un supporto anche per lui
quella alla fine l'ha portata lontano da
noi ma nonostante ciò li ci ha insegnato
l'insostenibile forza del sostegno
reciproco
questa storia sono tanto lontane quanto
vicine
perché sebbene la differenza d'età tra
piace annunzia ansia enorme
il supporto viaggia sempre sulla stessa
lunghezza d'onda e non ha limiti
pietro che con i suoi 80 anni sogna
ancora di cucire dalla camera della sua
casa di riposo
e nunzia che con i suoi 18 anni
ci fa ancora sognare attraverso il suo
ricordo e le sue lezioni di vita
perché il supporto viaggia sempre sulla
stessa lunghezza d'onda
ma siete sicuri che lo stesso valga nei
confronti dei più giovani noi abbiamo
tanto da dare ma la mancanza di supporto
da parte degli adulti coloro che
dovrebbero essere il nostro punto di
riferimento non fa altro che rallentare
il nostro percorso di crescita che
dovrebbe realizzarsi in un maniera sana
e serena è vero non possiamo aspettarci
dei cambiamenti nella società se non
siamo disposti e pronti a metterci in
gioco per ottenerli
quello che chiediamo è che dall'altra
parte venga ascoltata la nostra voce
senza alcun pregiudizio
dare voce solo così si potrà capire
quanto sia fondamentale la giovinezza
con la sua sensibilità una risorsa per
tutti